what is the goal of robotics what's the
general problem of robotics of trying to
solve you actually kind of painted two
pictures here one of the narrow one is
the general what in your view is the big
problem in robotics again ridiculously
philosophical questions I think that you
know maybe there are two ways I can
answer this question one is there's a
very pragmatic problem which is like
what would make robots
what would sort of maximize the
usefulness of robots and there the
answer might be something like a system
where a system that can perform whatever
task a human user sets for it you know
within the physical constraints of
course if you tell it to teleport to
another planet the probably can't do
that but if you ask it to do something
that's within its physical capability
then potentially with a little bit of
additional training or a little bit of
additional trial and error it ought to
be able to figure it out in much the
same way as like a human tele operator
ought to figure out how to drive the
robot to do that that's kind of a very
pragmatic view of what it would take to
kind of solve the the robotics problem
if you will but I think that there is a
second answer and that answer that
answers a lot closer to why I want to
work on robotics which is that I think
it's it's less about what it would take
to do a really good job in the world of
robotics but more the other way around
what robotics can bring to the table to
help us understand artificial
intelligence so your dream fundamentally
is to understand intelligence yes I
think that's the dream for many people
who actually work in this space I think
that there is there's something very
pragmatic and very useful about studying
robotics but I do think that a lot of
people that go into this field actually
you know the things that they draw
inspiration from are the potential for
robots to like help us learn about
intelligence and about ourselves so
that's that's fascinating that robotics
is basically the space by which you can
get closer to understanding the
fundamentals of artificial intelligence
so what is it about robotics that's
different from some of the other
approaches so if we look at
some of the early breakthroughs in deep
learning or in the computer vision space
and a natural language processing
there's really nice clean benchmarks
that a lot of people competed on and
thereby came off a lot of building ideas
what's the fundamental difference to you
between computer vision purely define an
image net and kind of the bigger
robotics problem so there are a couple
of things one is that with robotics you
kind of have you kinda have to take away
many of the crutches so you have to deal
with with both the the the particular
problems of perception control and so on
but we also have to deal with the
integration of those things and you know
classically we've always thought of the
integration as kind of a separate
problem so a class a kind of modular
engineering approaches that we solve the
individual subproblems then wire them
together and then the whole thing works
and one of the things that we've been
seeing over the last couple of decades
is that well maybe studying the thing as
a whole might lead to just like very
different solutions than we if we were
to study the parts and wire them
together so the integrative nature of
robotics research helps us see you know
the different perspectives on the
problem another part of the answer is
that with robotics it it casts a certain
paradox into very clever relief so that
this is sometimes referred to as more of
X paradox the idea that in artificial
intelligence things that are very hard
for people can be very easy for machines
and vice-versa things that are very easy
for people can be very hard for machines
so you know integral and differential
calculus is pretty difficult to learn
for people but if you program a computer
do it it can derive derivatives and
integrals for you all day long without
any trouble whereas some things like you
know drinking from a cup of water very
easy for a person to do very hard for a
robot to deal with and sometimes when we
see such blatant discrepancies that give
us a really strong hint that we're
missing something important so if we
really try to zero in on those
discrepancies we might find that little
bit that we're missing and it's not that
we need to make machines better or worse
at math and better at drinking water but
just that by studying those
discrepancies you might find some new
insight so that that could be that could
be in any space
have to be robotics but you're saying
yeah I get it's kind of interesting that
robotics seems to have a lot of those
discrepancies so that the the Hans Marva
paradox is probably referring to the
space of the the physical interaction
like you said object manipulation
walking all the kind of stuff we do in
the physical world that well how do you
make sense if you were to try to
disentangle the the Marwick paradox like
why is there such a gap in our intuition
about it why do you think manipulating
objects is so hard from everything
you've learned from applying
reinforcement learning in this space
yeah I think that one reason is maybe
that for many of the problems for many
of the other problems that we've studied
in AI and computer science and so on the
notion of input/output and supervision
is much much cleaner so computer vision
for example deals with very complex
inputs but it's comparatively a bit
easier at least up to some level of
abstraction to cast it as a very tightly
supervised problem it's compared to be
much much harder to cast robotic
manipulation as a very tightly
supervised problem you can do it it just
doesn't seem to work all that well so
you could say that well maybe we get a
labelled data set where we know exactly
which motor commands to send and then we
trained on that but for various reasons
that's not actually like such a great
solution and it also doesn't seem to be
even remotely similar to how people and
animals learn to do things because we're
not told by like our parents here's how
you fire your muscles in order to walk
we you know we do get some guidance but
the really low-level detailed stuff we
figure out mostly on our own and that's
what you mean by tightly coupled that
every single little sub action gets a
supervised signal of whether it's a good
one or not right so so while in computer
vision you could sort of imagine up to a
level of abstraction that maybe you know
somebody told you this is a car and this
is a cat and this is a dog in motor
control it's very clear that that was
not the case
you